Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show, I'm
Farron Cousins have been sitting in for David
Pakman this week and we have a lot to cover today,
so let's go ahead and jump right in. Obviously,
one of the biggest things happening right now
in the country that's not named Joe Manchin
is the Omicron variant. According to
the new numbers, the Omicron variant
now makes up 73 percent of new COVID cases. And of
course, with holiday travel happening right now,
these are the numbers from last Friday. Holiday
travel is happening. Holiday This weekend,
we can expect those numbers to climb even
higher. And that is why, of course, on Tuesday,
President Joe Biden, once again, just like he did
in September, came out and addressed the nation
to both soothe our fears and remind us that we can
protect ourselves, at least to a certain degree,
from this virus. He, just like in September,
again reiterated that this is becoming a pandemic
of the unvaccinated. And at this point, not
getting a booster shot is also kind of seen
as not being fully vaccinated. We are seeing a
drop off in efficacy. So if you got your vaccine,
your first two doses February March of this year,
depending on the vaccine, it could be down to
roughly a 40 percent efficacy compared to where
it was several months ago. If you do not get
vaccinated, you're still offered some protection
from it. Obviously, it does, of course, reduce
risk of hospitalization and death. But that is
why those booster shots are so important. These
vaccines do not last forever, this Amari
Moore in a vaccine is not a forever thing,
and booster shots may be something that we
have to live with for the foreseeable future.
And the Biden administration is also saying
we're going to get tests out to American
citizens, 500 million tests. They're pledging
so that is a step forward and of course,
that is due to pressure. It was only what a week
two weeks ago when Jen Psaki, during a press
conference, you know, kind of dismissed the idea
of giving the public free COVID tests. And now
suddenly it's a reality after everybody pushed
back on that issue. So the administration is
responding to pressure. Also worth noting, but off
topic the fact that now they're even considering
extending the student loan debt repayments,
pushing that back further down the road again,
this is due to public pressure. But it all
underscores obviously the bigger point here.
Omicron is running rampant here in the United
States, whereas a handful of weeks ago we had one
case out in California, one case in Minnesota.
Now it's seventy three point two percent
of all new cases. And of course, that number is
expected to rise. There's still too much we do
not know about Omicron. So again, the best advice
and this is what Biden is telling us is be safe.
We don't have to go into a panic, he told
us. We're not going back to lockdowns,
which I don't know. Maybe that is something
we should discuss here and here in America.
We never really had real lockdowns anyway. Let's
be honest about it. We had 50 different states,
two in 50 different things because our federal
government then run by the Trump administration,
didn't want to do anything. So that's why we got
pummeled with COVID in the first year. And then,
of course, by the time Biden came back, everything
was reopened. He didn't want to send us back to
lockdowns, and he still refuses to do that. So
I don't think regardless of how bad it gets,
I don't think Biden's going to put us back
in that situation anyway, even if we need it.
I think he feels kind of like Trump did
the optics of that in an election year.
Probably aren't going to look too great. So it
is what it is. If you're traveling this holiday
weekend, protect yourself. If you're going to
be around friends, family, any large group of
individuals indoors wear masks, if you can.
Socially distance, when possible, do what you
can to protect yourself, because Omicron does
appear, at least right now, to be a little more
permeable in the vaccinated, we're not
seeing obviously as severe of symptoms,
but it's still a threat. So please,
please, please protect yourselves out there